Bitte schön. Guten Tag. Mein Name ist Senola Haydn. Ich bin auf dieser Station als
Assistentin der Städtik und würde gerne mit denen das aufmörmige Gespräch hören.
Sind Sie damit ein Verstanden? Ja, wenn Sie mir helfen können Herr Doktor, dann bin ich
ja zufrieden, ja. Okay, nun frage ich ganz kurz zu Ihrer Person.
Nach, dann höre ich Ihren Bescheid so. Okay? Ja. Wie heißen Sie denn? Ich heiße Joachim Schläfer.
Joachim? Joachim? Ja. Schläfer. Schläfer? Ja, wie jemand der schläft. S-C-H-L-E, also A-Umlaut, F-E-R.
F-E-R. Okay. Herr Schläfer. Wie alt sind Sie? Ich bin 47 Jahre. 47. Wann sind Sie genaue Gebore?
Am 17., 4. 1975. Okay. Wie groß sind Sie? 1 Meter 83 steht in meinem Pass. 83. Okay. Und wie schwer sind Sie?
Ja, so 90 Kilo ungefähr. 90? Okay Herr Schläfer. Was für Sie ist so, was kann ich für Sie tun?
Ja, also ich habe so starke Schmerzen, so in der rechten Seite, also die sind wirklich stark, also gerade, das kommt so krampfartig zwischendurch,
dann kann ich kaum noch Luft bekommen, ja, also so stark sind diese Schmerzen und das strahlt also auch in die Leiste rein und auch so bis in die Genitalgegend.
Und ja, seit heute Morgen habe ich tatsächlich auch so Schmerzen, wenn ich Wasser lassen muss und ich muss auch ständig laufen, ja, also da kommt immer so ein ganz kleines bisschen.
Und ich habe auch gesehen, das sieht irgendwie blutig aus. Und weil ich solche Schmerzen habe, ich glaube, das hängt damit zusammen,
habe ich mich tatsächlich schon einmal übergeben in so einem Krampf, ja, weil die Schmerzen so enorm waren, ja.
Ich versuche dann immer irgendwo eine andere Position einzunehmen, aber die Schmerzen sind wirklich sehr heftig.
Okay, Herr Schleffer, einen Moment bitte. Wo sind die Genitalgegend Schmerzen? Sie haben rechte Seite gesagt.
Ja, so unterbauch oder... Bitte?
Rechten unterbauch oder flanken der Reifen? Nein, wir arbeiten oben, so bis in den Rücken rein.
Rücken.
Ja, Teil hier rum so ungefähr.
Okay, die Schmerzen strahlen in die Leistengegend und Genitalgen. Ja, genau.
Und seit wann haben Sie diese Schmerzen? Ja, das hat vielleicht schon heute Morgen angefangen, aber seit 2 Stunden ist es wirklich so heftig,
dass ich gesagt habe, ich muss jetzt zu Ihnen kommen.
Okay. Und Sie haben gesagt, dass die Schmerzen beim Wasser lassen. Ja.
Okay, ist Ihnen oder war Ihnen über? Ja, ich habe die gesagt, ich habe mich einmal übergeben, ne?
Einmal übergeben, okay.
Ja, ich denke mal, das hängt mit den Schmerzen zusammen, ja, weil das dann irgendwie zu viel war.
Wie sagt das? Er brach eine Auslösung.
Ja, das ist ein unverdauertes Essen, also wie so gelbliche stinkende Brühe, ja.
Okay, verstanden. Gibt es einen bestimmten Auslöser für die Schmerzen? Haben Sie das bereit?
Nein, das fing mit einmal an, ganz plötzlich.
Okay, ganz blödsich angefangen, aber Sie wissen keinen Auslöser.
Hatten Sie früher schon mal Ende des Schmerzen, oder?
Nee, kann ich mir jetzt nicht, kann nämlich nicht erinnern, dass ich so etwas schonmal hatte.
Okay, fühlst du dich fiebrig? Fiebrig?
Ja. Hab ich jetzt nicht gemessen, aber könnte sein, aber ich weiß es definitiv nicht.
Okay, haben Sie Schwisterfrust oder Schwitzen Sie übermäßig?
Schwitzen? Nein, nein, also waren Sie in der Nacht oder so.
Nein, also eigentlich habe ich jetzt nicht mehr geschwitzt.
Gibt es etwas, das die Schmerzen, die der Frust hat, wie zum Beispiel bei der Bewegeung oder bei Messen?
Ja, wenn so eine Krampfwelle kommt, dann krümme ich mich halt so zusammen, dann habe ich den Eindruck, dass es ein bisschen besser wird, dass ich es besser aushalten kann.
Aber vielleicht ist das auch Einbildung, ja.
Okay, denken Sie, dass die Schmerzen mit der Messen verbunden sind?
Mit dem Essen? Ja. Ganz bestimmt nicht, nein.
Okay, und Sie haben Luftnot? Luftnot? Ja, haben Sie Luftnot oder? Nein, habe ich nicht.
Nein. Okay, Sie können ganz gut Luftbecken haben, richtig? Ja, ja, ja.
Okay, haben Sie Gusten oder Brustschmerzen, Rückenschmerzen?
Na ja, also da an der Seite, das tut schon weh, ja, da wo das ausgeht, ja, das ist so mittlerer Rücken rechts, ja.
Da habe ich schon richtig heftige Schmerzen, ja, da zieht das so richtig rein, ja.
Okay, können Sie die Schmerzen genau beschreiben? Sie sind eher dumm, stetschend, sichend oder brennend?
Ich denke mal, dumm, dumm aber auch brennend würde ich sagen.
Okay. Und eben in so Wellen, dass das so ganz soll kommt.
Wellen vor mir, meine Sie. Okay, wie stark sind die Schmerzen auf einer Schmerzskala von 1 bis 10, wobei 1 sehr leicht und 10 sehr starken Schmerzen entspricht?
Also da würde ich jetzt schon sagen, die sind bestimmt bei 8. 8, okay.
Möchten Sie eine Schmerzmittel oder können Sie am Ende des Gesprächs aufseiten?
Ja, das wird ja jetzt nicht mehr so lange dauern, ich habe ja auch schon versucht, Ibuprofen zu nehmen, aber das hat irgendwie nicht geholfen.
Okay. Sie haben, Wulut, Imrin, wer merkt, das haben Sie gesagt?
Das war so ein bisschen rot verfärbt, ja.
Okay, wann haben Sie das bemerkt? Heute Morgen mit der Schmerz, oder?
Ja, ich glaube, heute Morgen war das ja.
Okay. Verstärken Sie sich die Schmerzen, weiter Bewegung, Treppensteigen, oder?
Ja, ich bin jetzt ja nicht mehr viel gelaufen, ich konnte mich ja kaum rühren vor Schmerzen, aber ich denke mal, dass es schon, dass ich froh bin, wenn ich sitzen kann und mich so ein bisschen zusammen gründen kann.
Herr Schäfer, haben Sie noch weitere Beschwerden?
Ja, ja.
Ist Ihnen Schwindelig?
Nein, Schwindelig ist mir auch nicht.
Okay.
Okay, sonst gehe ich zu allgemeinen Fragen über.
Schlafen Sie gut?
Ja, normalerweise schon.
Nachts habe ich tatsächlich nicht gut geschlafen.
Wegen der Schmerzen, oder?
Ja, irgendwie hat sich das schon so ein bisschen angebahnt, wohl ja.
Da war das aber noch nicht so schlimm.
Okay.
Haben Sie in der Saison seit 100 Jahren ab oder zu genommen?
Nein, ich glaube, ich bin immer das Gleiche.
Okay.
Haben Sie Probleme mit Stolkank?
Normalerweise nicht, auch jetzt nicht.
Okay.
Haben Sie irgendwer, der Corona-Konvention,
oder wie ist es, krank und von denen ihr wissen soll,
wie ist es, wie ist es, krank und von der Krank-Kait,
oder krank und von der Krank-Kait?
Ja, also ich habe ein bisschen Bluthochdruck.
Das hat man so vor vier Jahren festgestellt.
Seit vier Jahren?
Ja.
Was nehmen Sie gegen Bluthochdrück ein?
Südjahrzehn nehme ich ein.
Wie bitte?
Dieilthierzehn.
Okay.
Kennen Sie die Dosis von dieilthierzehn?
Ja, ich meine, es steht 90 drauf.
Dann nehme ich eine morgen und eine ab.
90, 90 Milligramm, Sie haben gesagt.
Okay, morgens und abends.
Okay.
Gibt es noch weitere chronische Erkrankungen?
Ja, also das sind nicht so richtig chronische Erkrankungen.
Ich habe halt durch die Arbeit, habe ich eine Sehnenentscheidung,
Sehnenentscheidendenzündung im rechten Arm.
Das will überhaupt nicht weggehen,
weil ich halt irgendwie viel mit den Händen arbeite.
Und da nehme ich halt nach Feierabend dann Diklofenachsalbe drauf.
Oder manchmal nehme ich dann auch eben Novolgientropfen
gegen die Schmerzen.
Okay.
Also diese Medikamente, Diklofenachkonschnalgin,
Beibedarf oder Regelnis?
Ja, Beibedarf, halt, wenn es wehtuch, genau.
Okay.
Sie haben Armrecht und Arm gesagt.
Was meine Sie damit?
Armrecht und Handgelenk oder Elemente?
Ja, also Unterarm, ne?
Unterarm.
Okay.
Ja, das werden Sie sehen.
Ich arbeite halt in meiner Bäckerei
und ich habe mir gestern eine Verbrennung dazu gezogen,
weil ich gegen einen heißen Blech gekommen bin.
Das passiert schon mal in meinem Beruf.
Wann ist das passiert?
Das war gestern.
Gestern.
Gestern morgens früh.
Wie wurden Sie gestern behauptet?
Oder was machen Sie?
Was haben Sie gemacht?
Ja, das macht sich selber mal wieder.
Ein bisschen gekühlt und...
Okay, verstanden.
Und gibt es noch andere Erkrankungen?
Sonst bin ich halt zum Glück gesund.
Okay, sehr gut.
Würden Sie schon mal operiert?
Nein, noch nie.
Nicht mal als Kind.
Nein, noch gar nicht.
Okay, sehr gut.
Herr Schäfer, Sie sind in nächster Zeit im Krankenhaus gelesen?
Nein, überhaupt nicht.
Nein.
Okay.
Eine Routine, noch eine Routine Frage.
Waren Sie in nächster Zeit im Haus noch?
Nein, schon lange nicht.
Sind Sie vollständig gegen Coronavirus und Kinderkrankheiten?
Ja, also ich habe alle Impfungen bekommen
und jetzt tatsächlich auch alle Corona-Impfungen bekommen.
Ja.
Okay, sehr gut.
Herr Schäfer, Sie haben schon gesagt,
dass Sie wild hier sind
und regelmäßig und nicht nur von der Grundmaualgen benutzen.
Und benutzen Sie noch andere Medikamente?
Nein, sonst nehme ich nichts.
Okay, sehr gut.
Haben Sie irgendeine Allergie oder umfärbliche Quests?
Oh ja, tatsächlich.
Also ich muss sehr aufpassen mit Westbin.
Das ist natürlich gefährlich in meinem Beruf.
Bei Westbin-Stichen da reagiere ich sehr.
Und ich habe auch tatsächlich eine Laktoseentoleranz.
Okay.
Schritt für Schritt geben wir Herr Schäfer.
Wie übersetzt sich Ihre Westbistichallergie?
Ja, also da kriege ich dann tatsächlich so ein rotes Gesicht
und da habe ich auch einmal fast keine Luft mehr bekommen.
Also das war ein bisschen gefährlich, da muss ich tatsächlich aufpassen.
Okay.
Und wie übersetzt sich die Laktoseentoleranz?
Ja, das, was man da so hat, dass man Blähungen und Durchfall hat.
Aber dadurch, dass ich das eigentlich vermeide
und vernünftig esse, habe ich damit kaum noch Probleme,
seit ich das weiß.
Okay, verstanden.
Gut.
Und Raouzi, Herr Schäfer?
Ja, seit fünf Jahren rauche ich zum Glück nicht mehr.
Bin ich sehr stolz.
Ich habe tatsächlich viele geraucht.
Ja, da habe ich 20 Jahre.
Gut 20 Jahre habe ich nicht geraucht.
Eine Schattel, ich habe sie ungefähr.
Okay.
Trinken Sie Alkohol?
Ja, Alkohol.
Also ich trink 2 bis 3 Bier am Abend nach der Arbeit so vom Schlafen gehen.
Ja, das brauche ich.
Nehmen Sie diese Frage nicht persönlich.
Das ist auch eine Routinefrage.
Konsumieren Sie Drogen?
Nein, nein, nein.
Nein.
Und gibt es eine ganz kronische oder wichtige Erkrankung
in Ihrer Familie, Herr Schäfer?
Ja, mein Vater, den ich in der
Zeit habe, der ist schon ziemlich mitgenommen.
Der hat so eine Gefäßerkrankung,
dass er durch Blutungsstörung hat in den Beinen.
Und der hat da auch eine offene Stelle.
Und das will überhaupt nicht zuheilen.
Und dem haben Sie tatsächlich auch schon eine Großzehe amputiert.
Ja.
Okay, um beide Mutter?
Meine Mutter ist eigentlich gesund.
Sie hat so ein bisschen Probleme mit der Wirbelsäule,
dass sie so eine Verkrummung hat.
Okay.
Wie alt ist Ihr Vater, Herr Schäfer?
Ja, der, lassen Sie mich überlegen.
Der ist so 72.
72.
Okay.
Und wie alt ist Ihre Mutter?
Die ist 70.
Okay.
Frau Bonsig, Ihr Schüster?
Nein, habe ich nicht.
Okay.
Sind Sie 3-Hai-Ratens?
Ja, ich bin noch verheiratet, lebe aber alleine.
Ich lebe getrennt von meiner Frau.
Frau Bonsig, Kinder?
Ja, wir haben 3 Kinder, die leben bei Ihrer Mutter.
3 Kinder?
Sind Sie gesund?
Die Kinder sind gesund, ja.
Ja, gesund.
Was machen Sie beruflich?
Sie haben schon gesagt, dass Sie in einer Begrie arbeiten.
Ja, das ist meine eigene Firma.
Ich bin selbstständig.
Ja, aber ich arbeite immer noch in der Firma mit,
also auch in der Backstube.
Ja.
Frau Bonsig, Stress bei der Arbeit?
Ja, das ist klar.
Da muss man schon gucken, dass alles klappt
und dass alles zur richtigen Zeit fertig ist.
Da ist zwar auch viel Routine, aber da geht es schon ziemlich rund.
Okay, verstanden Herr Schlepper.
Ich habe alles gefragt, was ich brauche.
Möchte ich Ihnen noch etwas hinzufügen?
Oder etwas fragen?
Ja, ich frage mich jetzt natürlich,
ob ich Schmerzen her und was kann man dagegen machen?
Ja, Herr Schlepper,
zuerst muss ich körperlich untersuchen
und dann einige Labo-Untersuchungen durchführen.
Dafür werde ich Ihnen das Blut abnehmen.
Und dann können wir widersprechen.
Ja, das ist gut.
Okay, sehr schön.
Okay, hat doch jemand Fragen an Herrn Schlepper?
Oder an mein Doktor?
Frau Wievermann, haben Sie mir gesagt, ich konnte nicht...
Ich habe gefragt, ob jemand von den Kollegen fragt.
Ich hatte aber keine Frage.
Ist alles dran gekommen?
Ja.
Doch, kommt was?
Das ist sehr gut.
Ja, das stimmt wirklich.
Wann haben Sie die Prüfung?
Am Samstag.
Am 6. Sonne.
Das läuft.
Wollen Sie schon präsentieren?
Ja, ich möchte präsentieren,
aber ich brauche eines, zwei, drei Minuten.
Okay, gut.
Die Frage, die eben kam, habe ich bestätigt.
Hab ich gesagt, haben Sie vielleicht nicht gehört?
Da war eine schriftliche Frage.
Brennen beim Wasserlassen, hat er gesagt.
Haben Sie den Fall schon mal gehört, Dr. Gündiz?
Ja, wir haben uns zusammen schon gemacht,
diese Patiente.
Ja, am 4. 1. ich habe es mir aufgeschrieben.
Ich habe eine Bericht geschrieben.
Das war Dr. Mimet.
Dr. Mimet hat den gemacht damals.
Ich nehme an unser Bremer.
Host sozusagen.
Dass er das war.
Der treu und brav immer noch unser Host ist.
Unser Offizieller.
Das ist ja wirklich, ja, sehr nett.
Haben Sie von dem, was gehört mal?
Was macht er?
Diese Patiente,
eine gleiche Patiente, Breiterweg.
Ja, ja, ja, ja.
Stimmt, die haben wir gemacht.
Ja, ich erinnere mich.
Ja, gut.
Aber nee, haben Sie von Dr. Mimet noch mal etwas gehört?
Was macht er jetzt?
Ich weiß nicht.
Sie wissen nicht.
Man geht ja ein Stück Weg zusammen.
Dann bricht es mit einmal ab, dann weiß man nicht mehr.
Dann denke ich immer, vielleicht gehe ich irgendwann mal zum Arzt.
Dann sitzt einer von Ihnen da.
Wer weiß, wie die Wege so gehen.
Wie viel Zeit haben Sie in der Prüfung zwischen
Aufnahme und Präsentation?
Haben Sie ein paar Minuten zwischendurch?
Hat man da auch Zeit zwischendurch?
20 Minuten.
20 Minuten sogar.
Sie haben diese Zeit zwischen 2 Teilen gepraktet.
Ja, genau, zwischen den beiden Teilen.
Normalerweise müssen nach der ersten Teil,
gibt es keine Lücke.
Aber schreiben wir erst mal.
Mit dem Arzt-Rief kann man dann auch gut präsentieren.
Ja, ja.
Insgesamt kann man ein bisschen denken.
Das ist immer gut, ja.
Nach 5 Minuten.
Und dürfen Sie am PC schreiben?
Oder müssen Sie für die Zeit?
Ja, ich habe das.
Ich habe das schon mal gehört, dass sich jemand,
dass ein Prüfer sich über die Handschrift beschwert hat.
Weil, ja, wenn es dann schnell geht.
Ja, und die Diogeneration,
die können ja überhaupt nicht mehr gut schreiben.
Die haben alles im Computer gemacht.
Ihr Leben lang.
Ja, das ist ja auch gut.
Sie haben alles im Computer gemacht.
Ihr Leben lang.
Und da ist das mit der Handschrift tatsächlich so ein Problem.
Herr Doktor, kann es losgehen?
Ja, okay.
Guten Tag Frau Oberersten, haben Sie Kurse seit für mich.
Ich habe 9 Patienten.
Danke.
Herr Joachim Schläfer ist
ein 47-jähriger Patient.
Der sieht bei uns seit gestern bestehender krankartiger.
Schmerzen im mittleren Bauch,
rechts, mit Ausstrahlung in die Italien
und rechte Leistung gegend.
Und er beschreibt die Schmerzen
als dumpf und als dumpf brennend
sowie wellenformig.
Und die Schmerzen würden auf einer Schmerz
eine 8 von 10 auf einer Schmerzskala
bereitet.
Und der Patient hat gegend
Schmerzen im Profen angenommen,
aber das hat ihnen nicht geholfen.
Und als begleitend Zymtome,
seitdem Patienten Polikusserie
und Hematurie,
sowie MEZ aufgefallen.
Desweiteren berichtet der Patient,
dass die Schmerzen in der Stasiatschirma
geworden sind.
Und er hat sich einmal
über Erbrochen
das Erbrochen war,
es war ein
sehr schwerer Erbrochen.
Und der Patient
hat die Schmerzen
in der Stasiatschirma
geholfen.
Und der Patient
hat die Schmerzen
in der Stasiatschirma
geholfen.
Und der Patient
hat die Schmerzen
in der Stasiatschirma
geholfen.
Und der Patient
hat die Schmerzen
in der Stasiatschirma
geholfen.
Und der Patient
hat die Schmerzen
in der Stasiatschirma
geholfen.
Zum Beispiel der Patient
hat die Schmerzen
in der Stasiatschirma geholfen.
Und der Patient
hat die Schmerzen
in der Stasiatschirma
geholfen.
mit Exantem und Duschen.
Sie haben Rotesgesicht gesagt.
Ich, ja. Mir ist warm, weil ich mich total aufgerichtet habe über die Nachrichten.
Rotesgesicht kann man exantem sagen, oder?
Ach so, ich meine, ich habe jetzt tatsächlich ein rotes Gesicht, ja.
Der Patient hat das gesagt.
Er kriegt so eine Flasche, so eine schnelle Hautrötung, wenn das so heiß wird.
Okay, verstanden.
Und er hat eine Laktoseintoleranz, die zur Methorismus und Diöre führt.
Der Patient ist seit fünf Jahren nicht raucher.
Dafür hat er 20 Jahre lang eine Schachtel geraucht, was 20 Pakusjahre entspricht.
Er trinkt 2, 3 Gläser Bier abends.
Drogenkonsum würde per Neu.
In der Familienanamnese fanden sich Ulkos Gruris beim Vater.
Deswegen hat er große Amputation.
Eine Großzähnamputation, okay, ja.
Okay. Und bei der Mutter, wir werden solle Verkrümmung.
Und der Patient ist ein sehr Kind.
Der Patient ist getrennt, lebt alleine, hat 3 Kinder.
Die Kinder leben mit ihrer Mutter und sie sind alle gesund.
Und er ist selbstständig und arbeitet in einer Bäckerei.
Bäckerei.
Und der Patient leidet und hat Stress bei der Arbeit.
Ja gut, kann man sich vorstellen, ja.
Gut, was ist denn jetzt Ihre Verdachtdiagnose?
Ja, meine Verdachtdiagnose ist Nephrolitiasis.
Und was wäre differentialdiagnostisch?
Als die Fernseherdiagnose kommen Holidokalitiasis und Enteritis.
Ja, möglicherweise, ja.
Passt nicht so ganz, ja.
Sustitis in Betrelacht.
Ja, so etwas, ja.
Handwuchsinfekt, ne?
Wobei die Schmerzen, die er beschreibt, wenn er bei 8 von 10 ist,
ist er ja schon ziemlich heftig, ne?
Ja.
Gut, was machen Sie denn jetzt mit ihm?
Zuerst würde ich natürlich körperlich untersuchen.
Ich würde Druckschmerzen, Lostalaschmerzen am Bauch kontrollieren.
Ja, was schließen Sie damit aus, was gerade gekommen ist, ne?
Ich möchte mit dieser Person die akute Abdomen ausschließen.
Apanditis, Pakretitis, Polyasistitis.
Und dann, ja, ich würde zwei Großdumige, sogenge, Anlegen,
und eine Galabo-Unterzogen, Nierenverte, Gebäudeverte,
und Kleines Blutbild, Blutbild, CRP, PSG.
Und dann Abdomenultrasonografie.
Ja, was machen Sie da, Polytechnisch noch?
Gerinux, Parameter.
Noch mal?
Gerinux, Gerinux, Parameter.
Ja, ich mache jetzt noch etwas anderes außerhalb des Blutes.
Ja, Urin Probe.
Wer macht das was?
Ja, wonach gucken wir da?
Sediment edir, prosytin sedimentin und nekosytin.
Unwürdlicherweise, Calcium.
Ja, Calcium.
Calcium, ja.
Und Röckenaufnahme des Abdomens.
Ja, woauf gucken Sie beim Abdomen-Sono?
Könnten Sie das nicht tun?
Wonach schauen Sie beim Abdomen-Sono?
Ja.
Bei der Sonografie kann man vielleicht die Steine sehen
und Armwegstau.
Ganz genau.
Kann ich feststellen.
Und natürlich ein anderes Ursaher des Akutes Abdomens.
Alles klar.
Ja, wunderbar.
Ja, wenn wir da etwas sehen, wie würde man dann weiter verfahren?
Weiter verfahren, ja.
Manchmal die Niersteinen kann selbst ausgeschieden werden.
Dafür werde ich Flüchtlings- und Geistusursch.
Genau, der kriegt das nur ohne, die war sein.
Ja, genau.
Anergesi, Schmerzmittel.
Auf alle Fälle braucht er es, ja.
Antimetika würde ich geben.
Ja.
Und dann Stoßweilenterapie kann surferfügelungsständig.
Genau.
Und Harmaite-Schiene kann einfokt darlesen.
Und die letzte Möglichkeit ist die Offen-Operation.
Genau.
Das richtet sich immer nach der Größe der Steine.
Und auch nach der Zusammensetzung,
wie weit die sich zerkrümeln lassen.
Also über ein Detotriptor,
ob sie verkleinert werden können.
Wenn das nicht klappt, dann muss man halt operieren.
Ja, super.
Ja, dann untersuchen Sie mal Ihren Patienten weiter.
Und berichten Sie mir bitte hinterher, was rausgekommen ist.
Und wie es ihm geht, den Herrn Schläfer.
Ja?
So, wunderbar.
Ich glaube, Sie können heute Nacht gut schlafen.
Und vor Ihrer Prüfung auch.
Danke schön.
Ja, das ist wirklich sehr, sehr gut gelaufen.
Haben Sie genau den Fall irgendwie schon mal kürzlich vor Augen gehabt?
Ich meine, das ist sogar ein Münchner Fall.
Ja, Münchner Fall.
Ich habe schon gelesen, aber zum meisten meine ich auch nicht.
Sehr geurte gemacht.
Ja, aber es ist tatsächlich ein Münchner Fall.
Insofern passt es ja ganz gut.
Das ist eine häufige Fall.
Ja gut, da habe ich mir nicht besonders Originales überlegt.
Ja, ich glaube, das ist ja auch dran.
Oder irgendwas anderes Schönes,
was Sie eben so locker bewältigen.
Also ich denke mal wirklich, Sie können sehr entspannt auf Montag gucken.
Ja, auf Sonnheim gucken.
Ich bin wieder heute ist, heute ist Donnerstag.
Ja, wir sind schon wieder am Ende der Woche.
Ja, okay.
Wie ist der Bedarf?
Ich stehe irgendwelche Prüfungen an in nächster Zeit.
Dass wir nochmal Sonnland an Termin brauchen, Dr. Gündus.
Ich oder André?